florida governor ron desantis firing
back at president biden over his
handling of the borders border surge
sounding the alarm over the
administration transporting migrants
all around the country unbeknownst to
the country no notice they do not tell
us
we have to sometimes do we we try to do
investigation
sometimes we've gotten some documents
given to us where we put two and two
together
but they do fly people in they fly in an
accompanied minors
you've got a lot of military-aged males
coming through
the border and it's not mostly mexicans
it's people from
asia the middle east africa haitians you
name it it's an issue beyond
covid because it's about the security of
our country
joining us right now fox news
contributor laura trump joins us laura
good morning to you
good morning steve great to be with you
uh governor desantis is exactly right
this is absolutely insane that our
federal government is able to just send
illegal immigrants
all over the country and i mean there is
a reason
that people are flocking in droves
across the country to florida it is
because of that man right there ron
desantis
he is a governor who has stood up in the
face of all the nonsense he has taken
a common sense logical and freedom-based
approach to covid
and i thought it was really amazing to
hear him push back
on what president biden tried to say
yesterday
about the state of florida and a couple
and he was responding to what
the president said i think on tuesday
afternoon in the east room where he said
you know the infection rate very high in
florida and texas and if the governors
aren't going to help just get out of the
way
well the president was also asked by our
white house correspondent mr president
if you're so worried about uh kovid
what about all the unvaccinated uh
people coming in from the southern
border
and the president said essentially i'm
paraphrasing well
we still have that title 42 and the only
people were
letting it across are unaccompanied
minors laura
that is not true
no of course it's not true everyone
knows that is not true
and the hypocrisy here i think is just
staggering
when you saw that the biden
administration yesterday steve
enacted something that basically says if
you are not a vaccinated person you
cannot travel
into the united states of america what
about the people
just flowing over our southern border
these people are not vaccinated
they have very high rates of covid they
are being shipped on on planes and buses
are given bus tickets and plane tickets
to go all over the country by the way on
the taxpayers
dime here in america and and you heard
from governor desantis
the states don't get any notice they're
coming in of course texas has a high
coveted rate of course florida does
these are particular states where these
migrants are headed they are shipped to
these states
and so i think it's ridiculous to
suggest that we're going to have to
we're going to enact a ban on people
coming in that aren't vaccinated
what about the southern border joe biden
yeah no kidding
all right meanwhile another hot topic is
a critical race theory which
is being taught in a number of schools a
public school teacher has actually
published a book it's called
a parent's guide to critical race theory
it's available apparently at amazon and
wherever you buy books
but the point is uh this is helpful
because this is somebody from the inside
a teacher explaining to the parents who
are worried about
how they do it yeah
critical race theory is poison for our
younger generations it's poison for
america it teaches us to judge one
another
based on the color of our skin not the
content of our character and teaches
people
to hate america it is not anything we
want in our schools and if you ever
wonder well
how would i know if it's being taught in
my school you're exactly right steve
this teacher
goes throughout this book and tells you
little tips to identify if you suspect
critical race theory is being taught
even in the smallest way
in your school he helps you identify it
he gives you tips on how to push back
against
it i think it's going to be really
important look the school year is
starting in a couple of weeks in many
states
across the country this is going to be
important to the future of america
every parent should pay attention to
this all right laura trump fox news
contributor
miam thank you very much thank you